voilà deux sur plaisance au
refinancement c'est normal de sa marge
en même temps seulement les en culotte
et soutien gorge pendant toute la pièce
évidemment ça aide c'est pas nouveau non
moi je non je ne me déshabille panne
n'était pas c'était pas c'était
patiemment c'est à dire qu'au départ je
n'ai pas écrit le rôle pour moi mais
c'est vrai que personnage délia ne se
déshabiller pas mais quand j'ai écrit la
pièce je savais pas du tout quel rôle
j'allais jouer et il se trouve que le
hasard a fait que finalement bien
finalement on va tous aller plus loin
sur ce terrain là vous allez voir on les
bouge pas pendant le génial
bien plus cette interview psy vous
connaissez non en fait je suis mythomane
mito un pont un peu parano beaucoup
schizo non maso vous aimez bien souffrir
un peu
psychologiquement ou physiquement j'ai
un doux mélange des deux quand même où
elle vient de passer ou mordus ça peut
arriver et ça donne ça va avec un petit
peu aussi un peu sado maso vous avez une
robe en vinyle chez vous vous êtes homo
j'ai essayé ça vous a pas plu si c'est
très excitant
ouais non vous êtes vibro non je vous
êtes trio nous plaît vous ai jamais
essayé non mais bien là dessus et encore
je veux bien le croire la toute petite
là le petit peu à bout un métier pas la
dépendance c'est son surnom quand elle
était petite et pas ce genre de chose
quand elle était petite toujours
d'appeler babouins
donc j'ai jamais essayé n'ont plus rien
ou non vous y essayer
franchement non je crois que ça doit
rester mais fantasmatique et ouais ouais
c'est de l'ordre du français je vous
êtes géronto c'est à partir de quel âge
50 points parce que pas du tout géré en
tout pas un peu notre ami avait inséré
vous a dit terry lhermitte à côté de
vous pas du tout un thierry le vrai
thierry lhermitte et ça boume nom et
vous des vieux
non non pas forcément vieux mais aux
fumeurs - pédo non à dos même pas les
ados exhibo bon chien
bah ouais ouais un peu exhib haut mais
chez vous aussi vous simplement sur la
scène oui je suis moi je suis tranquille
welch est seul il ya des gens qui ont
des voisins qui regarde je ne me soucie
pas les voisins ma version générique de
exhibo bien ce que je dis est ce que
vous êtes fétiche aux mamans pas du tout
porno vous regardez les cassettes pornos
ça peux m'amuser mais seul le temple sur
lot peut-être sur l'eau finalement cette
info non pas du tout pipeau non non et
disco très